breaking news tonight Metro Police
investigating a shooting near Nellis Air
Force Base from what we can tell much of
the area near North Las Vegas Boulevard
and Craig is being shut down Sasha
Loftus joins us now Sasha's live from
the scene and what are you seeing there
Sasha
Brian right now this main shopping
center
Craig right near Las Vegas
roped off with crime tape you can see
police Gathering here between the Jack
and Bob Jack in the Box rather and a
barbecue restaurant you see another
vehicle out there again in the parking
lot as you mentioned this is a shooting
investigation here near Nellis Air Force
Base at Craig and Las Vegas Boulevard
working on Gathering more information
confirming exactly what happened here
but for now I would avoid this area
altogether in terms of the road there
are a few delays a few lane closures
here on the edges of the road but the
road itself appears to be open again
police Gathering here between that Jack
In The Box and barbecue restaurant at
Craig and Las Vegas Boulevard where the
entire shopping center is blocked off
with crime scene tape in regards to the
shooting of course stay with 8 news now
on air and online as this story
continues to develop tonight reporting
live tonight Sasha Loftus 8 News Now